jordan peterson is a psychologist and
the author of 12 rules for life and
beyond order both of which are in the
description he's also a fellow
torontonian and a professor emeritus at
the university of toronto which is where
i went as well in november 2021 i was
lucky enough that jordan peterson
interviewed me for his youtube channel
which will also be in the description
and over the last few months it
accumulated several hundreds of
thousands of views
who would have guessed and we thought
perhaps it would be impactful to release
it here for a different audience knowing
kurt that is me it's a mixture of jordan
peterson interviewing me as well as me
interviewing jordan peterson as that
latter role is the one that i'm most
interested and comfortable in we
reference self-fulfilling beliefs deceit
perception
consciousness how does one
scientifically study it as well as the
definition of god if you'd like to hear
more podcasts like these then consider
visiting
patreon.com slash kurt jaymungal that's
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
and supporting with the contribution of
whatever you can or whatever you like as
the sponsors and the patrons are the
only reason that i'm able to do this
full time so thank you so much with
regard to sponsors there are just two
brilliant is the first one if you're
familiar with toe you're familiar with
brilliant but for those who don't know
brilliance is a place where you go to
learn math science and engineering
through these bite-sized interactive
learning experiences for example and i
keep saying this i would like to do a
podcast on information theory
particularly chiara marletto which is
david deutsch's student has a theory of
everything that she puts forward called
constructor theory which is heavily
contingent on information theory so i
took their course on random variable
distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take brilliance course it was the
first time that i could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive formula
that is to say that it would be
unnatural to define it in any other
manner visit brilliant.org toe that is
t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised that the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects you previously had a difficult
time grocking at some point i'll also go
through the courses and give a
recommendation in order the second
sponsor is less of a sponsor and more of
a recommendation for a podcast for the
inquisitive mind like yourself steven
pinker the renowned cognitive
psychologist who has been featured on
this channel before and will be soon
coming on again now has his own podcast
the life of the mind which sheds a great
deal of light on the mind the brain and
their inner workings the life of the
mind by stephen pinker takes us on a
psychological journey unearthing truths
about our own complex mind while
shattering common fallacies that are
deceptive and often weaken arguments
pinker shapes our understanding of how
our minds perceive what we see and
perceptions of theme in today's podcast
as well thus if the sections on
perception and comprehending reality
interest you then do check out his
podcast on youtube or your favorite
podcast catcher the links are below
thank you and enjoy jordan peterson
interviewing kurt j mungle interviewing
jordan peterson a note on the physical
mannerisms it's actually hilarious
watching this because it looks as if i
was mirroring jordan but this is
completely coincidental i had a blank
image on my screen specifically so i
didn't see jordan while i was speaking
to him as i was incredibly nervous
during this interview given that it's
the largest interview that i've done in
terms of platform reach
enjoy
if our perceptions evolved and we
evolved to adapt to reality and we don't
see objects
as the fundamental perceptual reality
then what does that say about reality
and that's not the answer to that
question is not bloody obvious
well that's another question i hope that
i can get to with with dawkins you know
and maybe he knows something that i
don't god i hope so
yeah see i want to make the claim that
it sounds then
and i believe you've made this claim
perhaps even viveki that the longer
something has persisted evolutionarily
the most quote unquote real it is
however however then one would be acting
as if there's something external
that we're trying to map out and then
the closer we are to that the closer our
map is to that reality of course we're
not trying to mistake the map in the
territory
well the whether or not material objects
exist
patterns exist
right and it's not obvious what the most
persistent patterns are
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to have
with me kurt jaimungle he's a toronto
based filmmaker with a background in
mathematics and physics who directed and
wrote the film better left unsaid which
was released in april 2021
that film explores the question of among
other things when does the left go too
far he's also the host of the theories
of everything podcast and youtube
channel which explores consciousness god
free will theoretical physics and which
just surpassed a hundred thousand
subscribers in about one year about one
year's time he's interviewed people
including stephen pinker noam chomsky
and john vervicky on the cognitive
science side
and stephen wolf from eric weinstein and
sabine haasenfelder
on the physics side
you can find out more
by visiting youtube.com forward slash
theories of everything or searching
theories of everything on spotify itunes
or virtually any of the other audio
platforms so you've been podcasting and
running this youtube channel for how
long about a year
yeah slightly longer than a year now the
channel's been up for approximately
three years in the sense that it was
registered three years ago but i've been
going at it with force for about one
year and a bit
so who who has who have you interviewed
that's been most popular
noam chomsky
and you're
you're
you're one of the reasons why because i
was the first person if not the only
person to ask him about you directly
oh so i don't know about that so there's
something we could talk about right away
so what did he have to say
i think that people who are on a certain
side on the political spectrum believe
their side
stands for what's good and the opposite
side is what's not good one of the
see that's so tricky man talking about
better left and said which we'll get to
later is how do you define the left and
the right it's decidedly difficult
almost everyone has a different
definition
chomsky would say well the left is
freedom and so anything that's on the
right is anti-freedom and the right
people who are on the right or identify
with being as such would
perhaps categorize it as the opposite
yeah well it's interesting at least that
they might circle around claims to some
uh let's say virtue that both of them
would admire like freedom
right so there's some agreement there
despite the different difference did he
point to anything particular about what
i hypothetically thought that made me
not
an acceptable sort of creature
no
it's somewhat it's somewhat hearsay in
the sense that he read an article based
on you so he didn't watch you directly
he read nathan robinson's critique of
you which i'm sure oh yeah well that'll
do it man
yeah yeah old nathan he's he's quite the
character
yeah i see so
well that's too bad in many regards did
you learn anything in particular from
talking to
dr chomsky
quite a significant amount as for what i
can point to let me think i spoke to him
six times
six times on the channel so the first
time about you i found it interesting
that he said
i asked each guest that i spoke to at
the time because now i've pivoted away
from politics for a reason for reasons
we can get to later i asked him
and every other guest when does the left
go too far in some sense it's a
petersonian question because you've
raised that quite a few times
when does the left go too far he said
well it's not a matter of going too far
for the left it's a matter of tactics as
for when does the right go too far so
while the right is
suicidal i think was his words
so that's that's interesting because
it's really not much of an answer i mean
i've been always looking for a technical
definition of that right it's like well
we know the right can go too far and we
know the left can go too far and
how do we point to
and i think this problem has actually
become more complicated rather than less
because the more i've been thinking
about it the more i think that
the errors on the left are
more in the nature of a vast number of
small errors mostly of
often of omission so the more um
reasonable people on the left
kowtow too rapidly to the more radical
types on the left especially at the
philosophical level and i think that
really happened at the universities
so well that's a one like that's
something we can explore well it's
actually a question i would have for you
why do you think that is i know that
this is mainly you interviewing me but
i'm still perplexed when it comes to
that why is it that the center left
doesn't excoriate the extreme left is it
because they're on the same side so the
enemy of my enemy is my friend or are
they afraid because
well they can get
you can lose even a tenured position
well i think there's i think that fear
and it isn't obvious to me that this is
merely a problem that affects the left
but i'm most familiar with it in the
university's circumstance and so what i
saw happening in my 25 years as a
faculty member let's say i think that's
about right
it's more than that actually but anyways
quite a long time three decades let's
say
um
was that
whenever the administration pushed on
the faculty
so in our faculty meetings for example
there would be administrative demands
and they were often unreasonable they
would increase the size of our our
seminars say for our third and fourth
year students ask us to do more work
with fewer resources and that was a
steady trend like if you look at
spending say on faculty salaries
versus spending on administrative
salaries across universities in the west
broadly speaking but certainly in north
america the amount spent on
administration just skyrocketed upward
whereas the amount spent on faculty
pretty much stayed constant
and so
why well it was because the faculty just
retreated continually every time they
were
challenged to say no and so i objected
repeatedly in faculty meetings whenever
that happened and said well why don't we
just say no they want to increase our
seminar size you know like double it
let's say in for third years that's not
a seminar anymore once you get to a
certain point
we just say no we're not doing that
why don't we just say no we won't do
that
well then they won't give us what we
want well they don't give you what you
want anyways
so like what's to lose
and but but so it was a thousand tiny
retreats and then
what happened after that was that the
administration having grown too
top-heavy
um
was taken over by people within the
administration let's say who had this
dei philosophy and they couldn't say no
to them
so
now so when did the left go too far well
it was micro retreats continual cowardly
micro retreats at the university level
now
sorry to be so long-winded about this
but there was something even more brutal
underneath all that
philosophically which i'm trying to lay
out in the new book that i'm writing
which is this post-modern problem and
the postmodern problem really emerged in
the 1960s with the simultaneously
simultaneous realization across a number
of disciplines
that there's almost an infinite number
of ways of perceiving anything and i
mean literally perceiving so when you
look at the world you see these things
you think are objects and they're sort
of self-evident but where an object
begins and where it ends is much more
difficult to compute than any one ever
realized which is partly why we don't
have
you know robots wandering around doing
things like dishwashing which turns out
to be insanely complex and it also
emerged in literary criticism with the
realization that well just as there were
an indefinite number of ways of looking
at something so actually acquiring the
objective facts of perception there was
an even more vaguely indefinable way of
in
way of potentially interpreting a text
or a canon of texts let's say so how do
we decide what's good and what's bad
literature what's deep and what's
shallow what's valid and invalid and the
answer is we don't know
that's the answer
but
premature answer was generated by social
critics on the left and the premature
answer was well all our categorize all
our categories and the active
categorization itself
serve the will to power
and that's true to some degree because
we're all totalitarian and and
authoritarian and narcissistic to some
degree we're also we also use deception
to get what we want so we can corrupt
our category structure but there's a
huge difference between
saying well we don't know the answer
but power may play a role
and saying the answer is that power
always plays a role and that's all there
is
and that's what's happened on the left
in the post-modern field and that sort
of fit in nicely with the you know the
idea that capitalism was essentially
uh oppressive and that the patriarchal
structure is essentially oppressive etc
etc and it's it's it's a it's an
unbelievably corrosive and terrible
philosophy
so
well the left went too far there to
claim that nothing but the will to power
governs categorization
and the act of categorization which is
basically consciousness itself that act
of categorization that you could not
possibly formulate a more
cynical
malevolent and
careless destructive philosophy
so
see what makes
this
so you interpreted the question as a as
a time question temporal one when does
the left go too far and i guess that's
within
that within when
and for me what you also laid out
ideologically what it is that they
believe that makes them go too far i
don't like to use the word ideological
we don't have to get into the
into the reasons there but for the sake
of speaking right now just use that word
why when do they go too far
ideologically see some of the people i
spoke to said the left goes too far when
it comes to violence well there's
something that leads to the violence
some idea
and you also mentioned
power right that also doesn't
distinguish the left going too far from
the right going too far right
so and and it's not a really good answer
because sometimes we think
sometimes we think that violence is
justified like in self-defense and so
often political violence
is
uh what would you say rationalized and
sometimes perhaps even functions as
self-defense and sometimes it's
rebellion against
true oppression
in which case
people on the left and the right might
regard
violence not only as necessary but
actually morally demanded right
ethically demanded so
the the mere use of violence and then of
course what constitutes violence that's
the next problem without or
it's it's it's too shallow an argument
to really get to the core of things
and one has to be extremely careful
about what
counts as self-defense especially
preemptive self-defense which is behind
much of what they do they'll say that
well we have to take action now against
the right or the extreme right which
pretty much everyone who is on the right
they would classify as being a part of
the alt right or alt light yeah well
that's that's another part yeah that's
another yeah
exactly well that's another part of this
tit for tat process that we see i think
perhaps accelerating it particularly in
the united states with the
return of trump let's say to the
political arena there's a tremendous
amount of distrust growing distrust on
both sides of the political spectrum
driven
well that's the question driven by what
certainly by the extreme views of a
minority on both sides
laying out the exact causal process is
extremely difficult because these things
they're not unidirectional
unidirectionally causal right they're
they they they cause each causes the
other you know i poke you you poke me i
slap you you slap me a little harder i
punch you you punch me you know and and
then we we have knives and we're at each
other's throats and we say well you know
who started it well maybe you said
something insulting before i poked you
you know who but
but the one of the things of interest
when observing something like that is
the causal process that's involved in
the tit for tat return and i've been
thinking about that a lot because i'm
for a whole variety of reasons that i
can't go into but jonathan height also
just wrote an article
about
positive feedback loop processes
operating at a very rapid scale on
facebook and twitter and exacerbating
this political
positive feedback loop right runaway
positive feedback loop you know you know
if you if you're doing any recording and
you bring your microphone too close to
the speaker that
that you're speaking through you'll get
this howl of feedback and that can
destroy the whole system the whole
recording system
um
and that's a good example of how a
positive feedback loop can get out of
control
and that's the real enemy
like if we're thinking meta-politically
the real enemy is
the possibility that
mutual distrust on both sides will
accelerate
uh our descent into a kind of melee
and
so the enemy isn't necessarily the
catastrophic ideology of the left or the
right but
the manner in which
extreme views
can
foster a spiral of violence that none of
us know how to stop
and it's stupid little things can
trigger like one of my friends today
sent me this
article showing that i think it was in
the virginia governor's race that
four
people
used ticky
lanterns and they were
hypothetically marching in support of
the republican candidate and so they
were posing as members of the
conspiratorial alt-right but two of them
were actually democrat operatives
political operatives trying to discredit
the republican campaign
and that's so dangerous because they're
basically acting out the proposition
that it's nazis you know for all intents
and purposes fascists that are
supporting the republicans and
to
that's such a terrible lie right it's
it's such a terrible lie to
to act that out to demonize your your
fellow citizens that way it's
unbelievably dangerous and
we got to stop doing things like that
you know and
all of us have to stop doing things like
that
right that may be at the bottom of it
what you mean there's so many ways that
this can be taken and i think that what
well it's difficult to say what's at the
bottom but one of the predominant
factors may be personalized
personal lies not personalized
yes i believe that i i really do believe
why why do you say that
right
see if you watch
the film toward the
fourth section i believe i split it up
into chapters and in the fourth section
it becomes much more philosophical which
was one of the reasons why i started it
because i happen to like puzzles and
philosophy it's one of the reasons i
went into math i like abstract thinking
so i tried to make a case about lies and
how lies spread now there's one obvious
route to take that with memes so you
talk about memes and how memes spread so
you don't want to pollute that because
that comes back to affect you if you
care about yourself first of all so
maybe you shouldn't care about yourself
so much
as for
see something i was exploring and i'm
not quite sure is it possible to tell a
lie without lying to yourself that seems
on the face of it yes all right well i
don't think so well
it seems like psychological evidence
well there's psychological evidence
though that you you can't well here
let's let's dig into that a little bit
so you tell a lie to yourself and you
think well i know the difference it's
like well
don't be so sure about that so here's
one experiment that and that's an
example so imagine that i give a group
of people a
scale that measures their political
belief about a certain issue
maybe the reality of climate change or
or the unreality of climate change for
that matter it doesn't matter and then i
get those same people to write an essay
of 500 words
outlining the contrary position
and they know they're just doing it
because it's part of the experiment but
then they come back a week later and i
give them the same political belief
scale
and what's happened is their beliefs
will have shifted substantially towards
the side that they argued for
okay so why well first of all
a lot of your so-called beliefs are
really low resolution
they're just heuristics they're like
single pixel images you haven't thought
it through very carefully imagine maybe
you know more than the average person
because of your background but imagine
how much you know about how a helicopter
works you know do you know what a
helicopter is yes no you don't if you
had to draw one it would look like a
four-year-old druid
you know you know what it you can
identify the shape in two dimensions you
know it flies that's about it you
couldn't fix one you certainly couldn't
build one so in a real sense you don't
know anything about a helicopter except
what you need as someone who's never
around helicopters to know and and most
things are way more complicated than
helicopters even though they're plenty
complicated and so you think that you
know something when you think you know
it but then you detail out a counter
argument and it turns out that you've
provided more detail in the counter
argument that you had in your argument
to begin with
so that shifts your cognition towards
what you argued for
well if you think that doesn't happen to
you when you're lying well you're you
don't know anything about how you work
and then the other thing is well
virtually no one thinks that lying is
acceptable morally when it comes right
down to it there might be specific
exceptions to that now and then and so
if you lie you're going to tilt what you
believe towards the lie because that
will
lighten the
ethical load that you carry it'll reduce
cognitive dissonance that's one way of
terming it
and so and then you can't keep track of
your lies and so that's a big problem
and they tangle up your thoughts and
then also let's say a whole bunch of
people really like your lie
well then you know most of us all of us
thrive on attention
i mean children will misbehave to get
attention even if it's negative
attention if they can't get it any other
way
and so
you lie and you you put it out on
twitter and you know ten thousand people
like it and then you think well wait a
sec
probably i believe that because look at
how positively it was received and some
of that's actually
socially positive right i mean if you
say something a lot of people respond to
it positively
that might be a good reason for you to
think that way a bit more right because
the fact that you want social approval
isn't only an index of your cowardice
it's also an index of your desire to be
productive and to fit in and to have
people like you and all of that
and so
lies
they just warp things to a tremendous
degree and if you think you're smart
enough to keep your lies separate from
your truth and then one final issue is
well let's say you lie 20 of the time
well doesn't that mean that you're
practicing to become 20 percent a liar
and don't you think you're getting
better at that
you you become what you practice
and then don't you think that'll
interfere with your ability to
distinguish between what you think and
what you don't think first of all and
also your ability to tell the difference
between truth and falsehood
and so and don't you think it'll make
you cynical about the nature of
humankind to observe yourself lying
you're certainly going to think other
people do it at least as much as you and
if they're bad people they do it way
more
it's just a rat's nest and you know i
became convinced a long time ago looking
at the totalitarian problem on the left
and the right that the most effective
way to deal with this fundamentally was
psychological and that what we need to
do all of us is to stop lying each of us
in our own lives
that's the solution we have to stop and
that partly that's because we're so damn
powerful now i mean how many people have
watched your podcasts do you think
they're in terms of views now obviously
that's a
there are multiple views for one
video
millions almost seven or so seven or
eight million
okay so how powerful might your lies be
right
right and i mean each of those million
people is connected to a thousand other
people
so
that's a billion people that you're two
steps away from at least
so you said sorry you said seven million
people so it's seven billion people you
know i mean obviously those circles are
going to overlap but you get my point
yeah what i would object to is that he
said most people would agree that
telling lies
is deleterious in some manner now i'd
say that they say that they profess it
but they don't truly believe it and the
reason that may in fact be what unifies
the extremes
i'll give you i'll give you an example
sure if you ask someone
i think that if you were to ask someone
is it okay to lie for the greater good
they would say
well the majority of those people on the
extremes would say yes and then i wonder
well hmm perhaps that's an indication
that you're on the extreme perhaps if
you have a world view i talk about this
concept called belton that's a good idea
man yeah perhaps if you have a veltan
xiaomi that says that there is no
that
somehow there is no greater somehow you
can't tell
a lie and before the greater good
because the truth and the good are tied
yeah i think that's right so i think
that's a really smart idea the idea that
if you have a belief system politically
that requires any lies to support
then that's an indication that you've
gone too far i think that's a good rule
of thumb
all right
and what else is as you mentioned it's
pestiferous because it's poisonous is
that
they they'll say power is one of the
well they'll say power is the
predominant perhaps only vector that
underlies our social interactions and
even truth claims and so on well
the issue with the issue with that is
that it's partly true and the reason is
see this cup here
this cup comprises many elements there's
an element of power in this cup there's
an element of art as well by the way
there's an element of physics you can
look at it mathematically you can look
at it through an engineering lens you
can look at it through an architectural
lens yeah well the power is the power in
the cup is for example that you own it
it's your cup right and so it's embedded
within a hierarchy now the quest so your
claim is exactly right um but there's a
huge difference between claiming that
it's useful to investigate the role that
arbitrary expression of power plays in
conceptual systems which is a perfectly
reasonable thing to say and
the premature answer that the
solution to the problem of perception is
will to power and nothing else and so
i've been talking to some evolutionary
biologists about that i talked to robert
trivers this week he's getting old and
it was interesting to talk to him but
we talked about psychopaths
okay so let let's let's wander down that
path just for a minute so imagine that
the patriarchal structure is predicated
on nothing but power
okay and then imagine that psychopaths
are particularly cunning uses of power
users of power
okay so then to the degree that the
social system is an expression of power
you'd expect psychopaths to be radically
successful
but they
or in in human populations
well they're also they also never exceed
they their numbers vary between one and
five percent in the population never
gets higher than three is really the
upper limit but it can get up to five
so they're not that successful because
97 percent of people aren't psychopaths
so
it
just that fact alone
indicates that there's something wrong
with the power claim
now you might say well psychopaths
aren't very good at utilizing power it's
like no no wait a minute
actually psychopaths are better at
utilizing pure power stripped completely
of empathy than anyone else
by definition
so they are literally the
power users who lack compassion
so
why aren't they radically successful in
human populations and the answer to that
is well because our hierarchies are not
fundamentally built on power
and our concepts and
and perceptions aren't fundamentally a
consequence of power or it's misused now
that doesn't mean that
our perceptions and our social
structures can't be and our intimate
relationships our relationships with
ourselves for that matter can't become
contaminated by
the excess desire for power
and by the deceit that might be employed
let's say in its service that obviously
that happens and we have to keep our
eyes open all the time about that
but the central claim is
not only is it
unbelievably cynical and destructive and
also extremely helpful if you want to
demonize your enemies you know because
if i believe that the entire basis of
your
perceptual structure is will to power
and so is mine let's say
well i don't if you don't
believe the same things i do so if
you're trying to elevate yourself in a
different hierarchy or you're trying to
produce a different hierarchy altogether
we have nothing in common except
our enmity because there's no ground
outside what you're striving for and
what i'm striving for selfishly where we
can meet as reasonable people and have a
you know soul-to-soul discussion that's
not even technically possible within
that freight within that scheme
and so that means that if you and i are
enemies well what am i supposed to do
with you
because all you are is will to power
i can't trust you i can't reason with
you reason doesn't even exist you know
you see echoes of that in the claims
that
rational discussion or something like
that is you know
especially the dialectical forms is
somehow a construction of white
supremacy
you know implicit in our social
structures
it's so
it's so shallow at that idea and the
idea that our virtues first of all that
there aren't any virtues but even if
there are they're only derivable from
power hierarchy structures god that's so
cynical and so destructive and so
dangerous and imagine just living with
that notion that that's what motivates
everyone is nothing but like an
untrammeled will to authoritarian power
god
that's hell man
yeah you mentioned the word use multiple
times and that is one of the reasons why
i try to analyze it more philosophically
toward the end because i don't think
that this is
see some people would say what we need
is dialogue
you'll see you'll hear this many of the
times it would come from people who are
on the center center right center left
they'll say we just need to speak to
each other more but i think what comes
before what comes prior to speaking is
we need to value the same
we need to be oriented in the same
direction yeah well that's again what
this new book that i'm writing is about
you know because there has to be a
there has to be an initial framework as
you said that makes even the possibility
of dialogue a reality so it's got to be
something look look what we're doing
right now you and me hopefully this is
what we're doing right he's like you
know some things and and i know yeah
that's right man hopefully and let's
bloody well pray that we are smart
enough and wise enough and careful
enough to do it right so it's not easy
you you come to this discussion
thinking maybe you don't know everything
and that i might have something to say
that would be useful and interesting to
you that that might actually be crucial
to you and i come to this dialogue
hoping for the same from you right so
first of all we both come
to the degree we're doing this properly
in an attitude of humility
i want to hear from you
and you know i tend to be kind of
dominant in conversations and i talk too
much and so that probably interferes
with it to some degree but i really do
try to listen and i really do hope that
when i talk to someone that's partly why
i do the podcast is that they'll tell me
something that someone is stupid and
potentially malevolent as me might
really need to know and so if i listen
real carefully
maybe they won't even know what it is
that i need to know that they know but
if i listen very carefully i kind of
call it out of them and then i can use
that information to correct myself so i
don't do something catastrophically
stupid in the future and hurt myself and
the people i love
and so you have to have this presumption
of
this presumption of ignorance
and
that the belief that the person across
from you particularly if they differ
from you
might have something useful to say
because they're different from you they
know things that aren't that you don't
know so isn't it so good that they're
different and then you have to believe
that
men of good will exist let's say and
that they can exchange information
that's mutually corrective and both can
walk away
better
and that's something like faith it's
faith well i think it's equivalent i
think it's equivalent to in the
christian sphere it's equivalent to the
faith in logos
it's it's the same thing
and logos is a very complicated concept
one of the reasons and i'm not quite
sure why this is the case but one of the
reasons this
theories of everything podcast has taken
off the way that it has is partly
because i'm not averse to this
ambiguous contradictory thinking when it
comes to metaphysical issues like
whether or not there exists a god and to
speak in terms of religious terms most
scientists are as you know and as i know
most scientists are
they find that to be anathema and i i
don't hey i'm going to talk to richard
dawkins oh well that's wonderful
yeah i saw your conversation with
lawrence krauss and i was well i have
yeah i did another one with harris too
just a week and a half ago and it went
real well i figured out how to do to
talk to sam better than i have before i
just asked mostly i just asked him
questions and that's really useful to
just to ask questions rather than
because i think i went sideways to some
degree in my discussions with sam which
i don't usually do
i was trying to prove something sideways
well
well i
like i said i was trying to prove
something instead of listening and
asking questions
and i should it would have been better
had i not tried to do that and just
tried harder and harder to understand
what it was that he thought
because one you know the more we talked
the more we found like real major points
of of agreement you know like sam is
oriented
to a great degree he's very much
concerned about the human tendency for
atrocity and malevolence
that drives him
that terror of that and that's i would
say that's my fundamental driver i hope
it is at least
and so that's something that really
unites us and he's hoping that he can
find
you know a genuine morality now he
believes he can find it in scientific
inquiry and and i don't think that's
true but whatever he might be right and
and it's not like i don't think science
can inform our moral choices and maybe
has to
but
i turn you know when i came out on the
public sphere and first talked to sam i
had this axe to grind in some sense
which was
my belief that the fundamental framework
from within which we see the world isn't
and can't be objective and i still
believe that's true but i i was
hammering at home because i wanted to
win that argument and that was that
wasn't the most sophisticated way of
going about it why less and less i think
as we talked
so and this time i didn't do that at all
i just asked him questions and we
definitely had the best conversation
we've ever had
so and i'm really hoping to do that with
dawkins it's like i don't want to win an
argument i don't want to have an
argument i want to ask him questions i
want to find out what he thinks because
dawkins is no fool great and his
atheistic materialism grounded in his
evolutionary thinking like
that's powerful you know it's it's a
powerful system of thought and he's a
master of it and so i want to find out
what led him to the conclusions that he
came to and i have questions for him you
know i want to talk to him for example
about the instinct to imitate because
you were talking earlier about something
that unites us you know
so imagine this for example
you know that the same person can be
admired by a lot of different people
even people who differ in their
political beliefs
and that that admiration sort of
captures them that's charisma that's
part of charisma
the charisma is part of an instinct
right because if i think you're
charismatic and then i'm going to watch
you more my eyes are going to point to
you more i'm going to be more likely to
do the things you do i'm more likely to
imitate you
and so i would say there's something
like a central spirit that we're all
driven to imitate
and it's the thing that we see as
admirable across people
and that points to something that we
experience as religious
so like the ultimate
expression
of that which is
that which compels imitation is
indistinguishable from religious worship
it's not propositional
yeah well that's a ver vacant argument
yes yes yes absolutely well and
verveiki's one of the people
who've who's thought this sort of thing
through mo in most detail
jonathan pageo as well and i know you
had him did he make the cut of your film
yeah and the director's cut
so just in the direction we're
if you'd like to watch the film it's
best to go to betterleftonsetfilm.com
because over there instead of itunes and
youtube and so on which you can also get
it from if you like if that's easier but
you can go to the url better left
unsaidfilm.com because over there for
the same price you get access to the
director's cut which has jonathan pajot
and i'm sure the listeners the watchers
of this are fans of jonathan
yeah well i think peugeot is super smart
man he's deep and same with verveiki
those two
they they've taken
certain forms of thought farther than
anybody i've ever met verveiki is so
well
read it's terrifying and
pagoda is this weird character because
he's he's he really understood you know
what he knows he's thinking
yeah yeah yeah well you see
well that's part of having an artistic
temperament too you know people like
that who are more open in trait terms
they can they can see patterns in things
now that can lead them astray because
you can you can project patterns into
you know the void let's say that aren't
there that's conspiratorial thinking for
example but
intuitive people
who are also capable of critical
thinking pick up patterns long before
anyone else does i've had graduate
students like that you know they would
leap to a scientific conclusion
that was dead on multiple times and then
they'd when they were writing their
papers they'd have to uh fill in how
they got there well that wasn't how they
got there they leaped from mountaintop
to mountaintop using nietzsche's
terminology and they could see patterns
and then they they had to construct a
rational story to publish their ideas in
scientific journals it's so funny
because it's a form of falsification
right that isn't how they got there but
but that's so that's one of the
questions i want to ask dawkins is like
well what about this instinct to imitate
do you think such a thing exists
you know because i don't believe he's a
blank slate theorist
and we're really good at abstracting out
things to imitate and so i started
thinking about this for example when i
was watching my kids play house
so my son would act out the father you
know he'd be the father but he wasn't
imitating me exactly he wasn't mimicking
the exact gestures of my body right like
i do this while i'm imitating you right
now
but if i was a comedian and i want to
parody you i would imitate your spirit
in some sense right and then put a twist
in it and everyone would laugh so i can
abstract out from you your pattern
well then imagine we're way better at it
than that like if i watched 10 admirable
men
and was gripped by my admiration for
them let's say i was fortunate enough to
have 10 admirable men in my family i
could abstract out the central spirit
that makes them all admirable and i
could imitate that
so what occurs when you keep doing that
over and over that's exactly right
across generations and so now partly
what occurs is the imagination
formulates the representation of the
abstraction
so i'll give you an example so if you
look in you often see this in byzantine
cathedral so you look up in a byzantine
cathedral it's a dome so that's the sky
and maybe you'll see an image of christ
up there as panto crater great creator
of the world this is sort of tied with
the idea that consciousness gives rise
to reality it's so it's an idealistic
philosophy or experience well the idea
is something like
that
the thing to be admired it's the central
phenomena and function of consciousness
and in some sense it gives rise to re to
the reality that it is good that is good
itself
and the imagination gets their way
before the propositional philosophers
way before the artists and the religious
streamers
you made an argument that that is
partly at least what is a religious
phenomenon now do you think that's only
it
no
i have another definition that i'm
working out okay so
it these are things i'm going to talk
about when i go to cambridge because i'm
going there to oxford and cambridge at
the end of november and
in any case so i'm also really
interested in the idea of depth
so we all have an intuition of yeah
depth d e p p pth like philosophical
depth or literary death or or the depth
of a conversation you know and if you
have a deep conversation you know you're
talking about weighty serious yeah
fundamental things okay well i have a
technical definition for that
we we have a hierarchy of beliefs
okay some beliefs have more beliefs
dependent on them than others
the more beliefs that are dependent on a
given belief the deeper that belief is
the deepest of those beliefs
we hold sacred by definition
by definition
our deepest beliefs are sacred their
their primary and you can tell that in
part because if they're challenged
you get unbelievably upset and the
reason you get upset is because well
you're not just destabilizing that
belief you're destabilizing all the
beliefs that depend on it and so
one
sacred belief in a marriage is uh
sexual fidelity let's say faithfulness
right and you kind of take that on faith
because while you take it's own faith
that you think that's valuable
in part but it's also on faith that your
partner is manifesting that
because you you know
all you have to do is get paranoid
and then you've you can accumulate
evidence that your partner isn't
trustworthy and no one's perfectly
trustworthy so you could see how right
exactly so but it's a fundamental belief
and then if you find out that your
partner's betrayed you well then the
whole house of cards perhaps not the
whole house of cards but a lot of the
cards come tumbling down you know
the past is no longer what you thought
it was
your whole faith in humanity itself
might be compromised including your
faith in yourself like it can really
it's a dagger in the depths especially
if you really
loved the person and really trusted them
so so say the more sacred a belief is
the deeper it is embedded in this
in this structure of beliefs and i don't
believe those are objective beliefs
that's another thing i want to talk to
talkings about i do not think the
scientific evidence suggests
that our perceptions
that what we perceive are material
objects
that are self-evident that we then
derive our conceptual systems from i
don't think there's any evidence for
that
i think it's wrong and it's been proven
wrong
so you know that's some of the places i
want to go
yeah tell me what you think of this now
i've only thought about this recently
i think when atheists
call the religious dogmedic what they
truly mean is that you're pantheistic
for low-level gods what i mean is
you what you've outlined is something
like this so let's say you have a
hierarchy and hopefully it's
monotheistic in the sense that you're
integrated which no one is but hopefully
it's you're pointing to one god one
source of good okay then you're like
well what makes me good and you keep
going down and down and down until you
get to extremely micro level actions
such as
type this email i'm typing this email
why so that i can get an approval for
someone for an interview why so that i
can talk and hopefully so on and so on
and so on and i think
i think you've outlined i'm pretty sure
it was you that it depends on so which
level there's the destruction that is
proportional to the anxiety that you
experience
okay that's exactly right so then i
think we know the neurophysiology of
that even
okay so then when
someone like sam harris calls someone
else
dogmatic
essentially what they mean is that why
are you getting upset at this level why
are you holding this to be sacred
so here's another example to people who
are fundamental in their religious views
so they believe it's literal what's in
the bible is literal something i think
about is and even people who think the
bible is entirely metaphorical
if i say well what if let's imagine i'm
speaking to a fundamentalist if i say
what if this aspect of the bible is not
meant to be literal it's metaphorical
they get upset
why do you get upset why is your belief
in god contingent should your belief in
god be contingent or should you have
faith no matter what
okay so then they would say well well so
why does that undermine your belief to
me faith
should be
well it shouldn't be so easily
undermined
and so in some sense it's as if they're
saying here is my god instead of at the
top level well here what oh yeah they
are well here okay well so let's dig
into that a little bit that's a very
good observation well
one of their unrecognized gods
is
literal
the the phrase itself
because literal means real
and it means ultimately real but literal
doesn't mean real or ultimately real
necessarily
like literals really like
what does a dostoevsky novel literally
mean
well nothing
well none of it's true
it didn't happen or did it or did it
really happen like at a meta level well
that's where great novels happen is at a
meta level so truth is complicated and
this is see so the fundamentalists
they're they're tripped up
philosophically to some degree because
they
they they can't see how something can be
oh my god it's so complicated this is
where sam harris and i kept going off on
you know different tangents
they don't know what they mean when they
say literal they equate literal with
real they create real with material real
like and so when you go after that and
you say well it's not literally true
what you're saying what you're
essentially saying is that well your
whole belief system is predicated on a
misapprehension
even about the nature of god let's say
i mean you know most religious
traditions many religious traditions
insist that
representing god in a concrete manner is
actually
an error
the taoists are not very happy with that
idea that muslims certainly aren't uh
the orthodox christians really don't
many of them really don't like to
represent god the father in their
iconography and part of the reason for
that is that
you shouldn't concretize the absolute
it's
dangerous now it's a problem because if
you don't concretize it you can't act it
out so there's a tension but
you know when people say
people ask me if i believe in god and i
always think well there's a whole bunch
of assumptions in that question that you
want me to swallow so that you can
categorize my answer according to your
pre-existing schemas and that isn't an
answer they like
but
it's an equation right is
god real god real well what do you mean
by real
right you know what i mean no i don't do
you mean real like a table
real like the table you they don't know
they just think they know it's just like
the helicopter issue it's like do you
mean the table do you mean the table you
know do you mean your table
do you mean tables in general as real
do they have to have four legs do they
have to have a hard top
like what are we talking about when we
mean real do we mean objectively real
like a table well god isn't like a table
well then he isn't real it's like okay
well have it your way if that's as far
as your thinking goes
but i don't even think that
sophisticated
sophisticated religious people whether
they know it or not
don't think that god is a is real like a
table
and and as you already pointed out when
you with your discussion about your cup
even what exactly constitutes a table is
subject to great
so it's not obvious look one of the most
one of the most
one of the most
impressive
thinkers i ever encountered
in the field of perception
wrote this book called an ecological
approach to visual perception
and he would say that a table is a um
i always forget his name it's an
ecological approach to visual perception
gibson yes yes okay so
when you see a table do you see an
a flat surface with four legs
or do you see a sitting down to eat
place
and the answer is you see a sitting down
to eat place
and there are objects that slot into
that category that's the answer it's not
the other way around you don't see the
material object which is self-evident
and infer the function
now it might be a combination of those
two things as well but it doesn't matter
the the functional element of it has a
certain perceptual primacy and i'll give
you a kind of a nifty example of this
there is a neurological condition called
utilization behavior which accompanies
prefrontal damage
and
if someone has manifest utilization
behavior if you give them an object they
can't not use it
so because what's happened is
when they see a cup they'll lift it up
and drink from it because a cup is a
lifting up and drinking thing
perceptually it grip it grips their
motor output they can't inhibit it so
but the fact that they have to inhibit
it shows how low level the functional
perception is
right and so so
so and that's part of what i was trying
to lay out with harris is that
you know
the idea that the most real is the
objective
doesn't seem to be true for our
perceptions and then that tangles us up
scientifically right because
if our perceptions evolved
and we evolved to adapt to reality and
we don't see objects as the fundamental
perceptual reality then what does that
say about reality
and that's not what the answer to that
question is not bloody obvious
well that's another question i hope that
i can get to with with dawkins
you know
and maybe he knows something that i
don't god i hope so
yeah see i want to make the claim that
it sounds then
and i believe you've made this claim
perhaps even for reiki that the longer
something has persisted evolutionarily
the most quote unquote real it is
however however then one would be acting
as if there's something external
that we're trying to map out and then
the closer we are to that the closer our
map is to that reality of course we're
not trying to mistake the map in the
territory
well the whether or not material objects
exist
patterns exist
right and it's not obvious what the most
persistent patterns are
like it looks to me and you can talk
about archetypes in this wise i would
say to some degree
trees have been around a long time and
the tree structure is pretty embedded in
our perceptual perceptual systems
and
so
there there is a relationship between
how long something has been around in
our environment and how
deep that is within our perceptual
structures
you know like we as we assume a
difference between up and down
for example that's really built into us
and it's it's at the basis of a lot of
our metaphors up is you know high up in
the sky up is uh elevated up is the
mountaintop up is the sage up is god
well that's partly because we're up and
down creatures because there's gravity
and there's the ground and we're stuck
to the ground and the ground is base and
it's material and it's dirty and the sky
is pure and
etc etc
a lot of our metaphorical architecture
is predicated on these underlying
presumptions and they do have a depth
and
that's also partly why the biological
question in relationship to ethics
becomes complex too because
some of these adaptations to
permanent patterns
are
biological
fundamentals right and so
and if
utilization is part of that then
evolution of god would you say
persistent patterns that we've
encountered over our evolutionary
history have shaped the
axioms of our
ethics
it's complicated man like all this stuff
is
but
okay so where i was going well you said
quite a
you said quite
quite a significant amount
let me see
[Music]
okay so i'll just go down one route i
don't know if you're aware of donald
hoffman
the name doesn't ring a bell okay so
donald hoffman
is a cognitive scientist who makes the
claim that what we see is not reality it
almost certainly cannot be and the
reason is that
the amount of ways that reality could be
versus the amount of ways you could
perceive there's a it
so let's say the amount of ways reality
could be is at the bottom and then you
have on the the numerator the amount of
weights that you perceive that tends to
zero
for anything that's even remotely
complicated which we are more than
remotely complicated well look you've
watched um the simpsons or south park
south park's even a better example
well
it's barely animation at all south park
you know it's just icons moving
you don't care
that's good enough
and it doesn't matter that in fact it's
kind of an interesting style and it
doesn't clutter up the story right and
so what you see is an icon now
look
if you see an icon and the pixels in the
icon are random samples of the
underlying reality
then
and the reality doesn't change during
the act of perception then
you're still seeing reality but you're
seeing it at very low resolution and i
think that's a better way of thinking
about it
it's low resolution it's not not real
and you don't you actually don't want
your representations to be any higher
resolution than necessary so imagine on
a computer sometimes you want a
thumbnail
because that's good enough and sometimes
you want a high resolution photo because
you need detail
and that's a really good way of thinking
about our perceptions
they're low and then also our our
heuristics
so i think that each of us has a
complete map of the world
now you might say well we can't because
we're ignorant and the world's real
complicated it's like yeah but we just
cover up what we don't
perceive in detail with a low resolution
map
and so
things we haven't delved into in detail
are mapped in a very low resolution way
and that's good enough as long as when
we use the representation we don't
encounter an error
like so so it works
and if it doesn't work well then you
have to decompose the
you have an explanation for in some
sense a representation of everything
it's just low resolution
like like think of the word sky
okay that's an e that's that's that's an
icon the word is an icon so you could
think the word is a representation of an
image of a representation of reality
so when you look at the sky you don't
see the sky
like let's say you're looking up in the
night sky i mean god live there's a
hundred billion galaxies up there you
don't see them
you see a low-res representation and
then you make that even lower res by
saying sky
well is that good enough well it's good
enough you don't get hit by a meteor
when you're out there on the deck
standing looking up at the sky because
it it does the trick for the time
that's a pragmatic preg that's a
pragmatic approach to truth to some
degree
you know
it works well enough for your current
purposes
complete enough for you to act in the
manner that produces the result you
you want not the result you predict the
one you actually want it doesn't always
occur like that yeah it's not
no well of course not because because
it's partly because our our low res reps
our representations are fallible
immensely fallible
but often they're good enough
you know when you were speaking to
harris what i thought was underlying the
disagreement between you two and even
with you and brett weinstein about truth
is that there's the implicit assumption
that one should pursue true
so i don't know if that's the case but
when you're referring to truth and
you're saying well here's the definition
of truth and if we were to just follow
blindly scientific truth we would build
animals which we have we could destroy
us there are many paths that can go that
aren't salutary so we should pick
and write we're saying well one is
explanatory well who cares about
explanatory we care about our life
uh
to me what was at the un
to me what was underneath it was that we
should pursue truth is that am i correct
in my assessment or was there something
else
so what if one made the claim that we
don't always have to pursue truth
well we can't pursue it everywhere right
there has to be a spirit that animates
the pursuit of truth
to give it some direction well look
here's an example i think i probably
used this in my discussions with harris
i read this book once about
biological warfare research in the
soviet union and it's pretty damn
relevant in the case of wuhan let's say
you know and god only knows what
happened there but
in any case demonetized right now there
were soviet scientists working on
combining
trying to make a hybrid
between
smallpox and
ebola what's that that does the ebola
right right right right
and then to make it deliverable in
aerosols
well how about maybe not
how about maybe we don't go there
you know and and scientists are making
decisions like that all the time because
there's an infinite number of facts to
study see this is the problem with the
pure science argument follow the science
it's like well there's an infinite
number of facts
this is a problem so science is all
about the facts yeah
which facts and then that gets us into
the post-modernist dilemma because the
post-modernists say only those facts
that serve the will to power and your
particular will to power that's just
very cynical way of looking at science
so
but but but there's still the question
there right something is directing this
some and something needs to be directing
this and and i would think harrison
weinstein and myself would all agree
that the pursuit of truth is of
exceptional importance and also that
there are methods for
distinguishing let's say
material facts scientific facts from
ethical facts now that's where it gets
trickier and the relationship between
those two
i don't think you can look at the facts
except through an ethical framework i
don't think it's possible
the ethical framework is built into your
perception
i see you can't help it and the reason
for that it's it's technically quite
straightforward i believe is that we are
fundamentally
ambulatory and goal-directed creatures
we walk we move we're always moving from
point a to point b always no matter what
even when we're looking at something
it's in preparation for a movement to
someone bet somewhere better
you know unless we're trying actively to
make things worse but that's an
exceptional case
we can't help but look at the world
what we see is a map
that's a that's a good way of thinking
about it we don't see the world we see
our map of the world and we need a map
because we have to walk through the
world
and we don't want to have things fall on
us etc we don't want to get lost
and so and then we we might infer
objects from the contents of our maps
and we might even say those objects are
fundamentally real but then you know
that's a problem because the question
then arises well what do you mean by
real exactly and exactly why
and you know then sam would say well you
can derive what's real from science and
i would say well there's an infinite
number of facts sam how the hell do we
decide which facts to pursue and which
not to pursue and which we shouldn't
pursue
and you think here's something
interesting about the scientific
literature
you write a research report about your
experiment you almost never
tell the truth about why you got
interested in that
what you do is you lay out this rational
argument that led to your hypothesis
which isn't what led to your hypothesis
at all by the way it's just a summary
statement that other people could follow
it's not an actual description of what
happened you're interested in something
for some reason
and that shapes your hypothesis and the
direction of your research and that's
tied in with your own personal narrative
so
it bedevils the scientific enterprise
and it can be a real problem because
your own narrative can you know cloud
your judgment of the let's say the
relevant fact
so
the epitome of that is this
mathematician named romana jan have you
heard of ramanajan
yes
okay for those who haven't heard of him
he would come up through intuition or
through what he would say would be dream
encounters with gods or god it says
he would come up with what are
astounding
formulas
that
i remember i think it was hardy who was
the supervisor said you can't simply
make these up they're too baroque for
you to make them up and they turned out
to be correct and what you're saying is
well
okay how do you justify that well
that was one of the problems with him
what he would is that he would spit out
these formulas which in the end most of
the time turned out to be true slight
modifications of what's true and i'll
give an example if someone wants to if
someone can keep this in their head okay
so how many ways can you partition a
certain number so let's say 26 can be
written as 1 plus 1 plus 26 times or it
can be written as 1 plus 2 and then plus
1 1. so there are many many different
partitions of a natural number
he came up with this formula that the
number the partitions of any number
something like 1 over 2 pi square root 6
then you take the derivative of what's
happening here which is exponential
1 over 2 pi over square root of 6
square root of n minus 1 over 24 all
over square root of n minus 1 over 24.
and he couldn't neces now i'm not sure
about that particular one doesn't matter
this is an example he couldn't prove
them and he would say that he just
they just occurred to him
so
that to me is well i'm wondering well
that's a mystery there's no one else in
mathematics that was like that
and i'm not sure if that's because he
was terribly open like you mentioned
openness is a trait that allows you to
have this these
large leaps of insight i'm not sure if
that's exactly why it could be
but that's an example
yeah well you know the the
the the depths of what inspires us are
that's a great mystery right i mean one
of the mysteries of the scientific
enterprise for example is hypothesis
generation you know when we train
graduate students we we spend a lot of
time
training them in
method let's say and approach and then
writing scientific papers and so on but
there's almost no
strict
pedagogy in relationship to hypothesis
generation well where do you come up
with your research questions to begin
with well i'm interested in that it's
like well that's really not much of an
answer it's certainly not formalized
very well what what is that interest
exactly and how does it guide you
exactly and
what is that and then you might say well
and also how is that related to your
morality like to what degree is your
scientific
curiosity motivated by your own personal
desire for success or maybe the desire
to serve others you know on the virtuous
side
etc etc well that's just
that's just often the domain of well we
don't ask those questions when we're
scientists
and fair enough in some sense but not
really because well you do run the kind
of problems you just described
you know i work with this carver um
he's a member of uh
native canadian tribe no it's charles
joseph is his name and he's quite a
remarkable person and he carves these
traditional west coast native canadian
quack quack sculptures and he dreams
in those images
and he consults with
the spirits of his father and
grandfather great grandfather in
particular in his dreams about his
carvings and he doesn't talk about that
with anyone because they think he's
crazy but he's not
he's definitely not
and he's a great artist in my estimation
unbelievably creative and that his
creative process is so
unique that
well it's remarkable to listen to him
you know and he's the inheritor of an
unbroken tradition that stems back
perhaps
15 000 years
yep you brought that up to krauss that
the science well you said science is
nested within
what you would consider to be the
religious domain and you could give an
example by motivation what do you what
motivates you to pursue a certain
direction so sure once you've gotten to
that direction it's then a scientific
and then he said well look you can't can
you point to me
any
fact let's say that the religious has
come up with something like that he said
and or knowledge and then the question
was well what does one mean by knowledge
and to me it's it's a soulless way of
looking at the world they devoided the
world of soul to begin with and then
wonder where is the soul so it's like
you've watched someone you take it take
right now you if i go there and i open
up the fridge and i and i say to you or
you say hey kurt had kurt had some soul
that made him get up and go to the
fridge and then they say well where what
pixel where was that soul at what point
when his fingers touched the fridge did
the soul come in well the soul was
behind that sure at the lowest level it
wasn't but the soul is somewhere at the
top well what is the soul
yeah well they
look i mean i think it's perfectly
reasonable to point out that there's no
spirit in science in some sense
because we chased it out when we
developed a scientific methodology right
and there may be an equation
it's a related
it is a related problem i'm going to
talk to penrose by the way also when i
go to oh wonderful and about that
because
penrose thinks that consciousness is not
computational and i don't understand why
he thinks that i mean i'm talking to
computer engineers who are building
ai brains fundamentally and they're
quite confident if you like
hey go right ahead sure sure so i've
studied penrose and spoken to his
partner
stuart hameroff on the podcast
so the reason penrose fundamentally
thinks that it's not computational is
because of girdles and completeness
theorem the fact that so if it's
computational in some sense that means
it's a first-order language now because
of girdles and completeness theorem we
can generate a proposition that we see
as true but the force first order
language cannot see that it's true and
this can happen over and over again
they actually accept that interpretation
of goodell's incompleteness theorem
because i proposed that in my book maps
of meaning and a number of philosoph
philosophical critics have said that i
misunderstood that
that incompleteness theorem that didn't
have any application in the domain of
philosophical inquiry but i thought it
was also an argument about first
principles that any internally coherent
system had to be predicated on axioms
that weren't provable from within the
confines of the system
and so that's part of penrose's issue
here is it it's the first principle
issue
yeah now i'm unsure exactly what you
said in maps and meaning that would make
a
philosopher raise alarm well they just
said it was inappropriate of me to imp
first of all that i misunderstood
goodell's incompleteness theorem which i
might have because i'm not a
mathematician but that even if i did
understand it it wasn't appropriate to
apply it to like systems of
philosophical inquiry outside the strict
domain of mathematics and
that was their criticism but and i've
always been so leery about that because
i was kind of outside my domain of
expertise when i incorporated that
argument but it did look to me like it
it was this it was a statement i think
what godel goodell meant was that
there you can't have a system of usable
thought in some sense that isn't
predicated on axioms that stand outside
the system
uh-huh
uh-huh you see i recall reading an
article of yours about a year or two
years maybe even three years ago about
girdles and completeness theorem and god
how girdles and completeness there in
some sense proves god and then when i
was searching for it again i couldn't
find it do you recall writing an article
about it i don't think no no i don't
think i made that no i don't think i
made that argument
so
so
but i could ask penrose about that yeah
very sure yeah well it it the uh the uh
the question if that interpretation is
correct and if this is the issue that
that penrose is trying to uh uh solve
i'd be very interested in that so thank
you for that because i'll ask him but
the the fact that there have to see i
think there have to be axioms outside
the system say the propositional system
because something has to fill in the
gaps
that our ignorance leaves
because we have to map the world but we
can't because we're ignorant and so what
do we do well we have assumptions and
even our perceptions are assumptions
you know for example i'm i'm watching
you and
i'm acting as if what you're doing is
telling me the truth
but that's an assumption
now it could be a generous assumption it
could be a necessary assumption but
a lot there are going to be times when
that assumption which is a perceptual
act because i see you that way right in
the broader sense of seeing
there's going to be times when that's
wrong because i'm talking to someone who
isn't telling me the truth because they
don't know what they're talking about
let's say that's ignorance or maybe
they're being malevolent
so we fill in the gaps between our
propositional knowledge and the
infinitely complex world with
presumptions
and a lot of those presumptions are
perception so i think of perceptions as
the axioms of propositional thought
that's part of it
because thought is about something right
yeah penrose is what penrose would come
from
maybe it's adjacent but an alternate
route that
is about understanding the fact that we
can understand a statement to be true
and it came from a first order language
but that first order language cannot see
that it's true that we understand it
implies that what we're doing is not
computational and the reason is that
let's imagine we could find the
computational
see
this guy named stephen wolfram who
believes that what underlies reality
something like hyper graphs and then
there's a computation there's a rule
that there's rule of there's a system of
rewriting
now that's akin to a first order
language however there would be let's
imagine that's the case at the
at the fundamental of physics is
something like a rule generation process
that's like a first-order language well
then we can
find a rule sorry we can find a
statement that this rule cannot see as
being true but then we see it as true
so how is it that we could be generated
by this for if we're embedded in the
first order language how is it that we
can see what how is it that we can
understand that to be true when we're
generated by it okay so so let me okay
so that was part of the reason that jung
hypothesized the existence of a
transcendent self
so imagine that as you go through the
different
manifestations of your personality in
your life you know you say i radically
changed at some point
you look at retrospectively and you say
are radically changed well imagine that
there's these
map systems that you identify with you
say that's me
your ego identifies with them you say
that's me but then that changes
radically and maybe you fall into chaos
when it changes because you you lose
your belief and then a new belief
emerges out well it emerges out of
something underneath
and so jung posited that part of what
the self was was the thing that remained
constant across transformations
and actually guided them in some sense
now young also believed that christ
technically speaking psychologically
speaking was a symbol of the self
and that's partly why the death and
redemption idea rings true with us
because we all go through partial deaths
and descents into sometimes into hell
you know when everything falls apart
around you you know to think about that
as a descent into hell it's perfectly
reasonable metaphorical statement it
certainly feels like an eternity when
you're there
and in some sense that domain has always
existed right across the span of
humanity and it's a place you can go
it's also a place that deceit is very
likely to take you because it makes your
these
presumption systems very fragile and
much more likely to degenerate into a
chaotic hell
in any case the self is the thing that's
underneath that that remains constant
but also the thing that guides those
transformations and even more
importantly in some sense it's the thing
that gives us the intuitions that guides
those transformations towards a higher
order form of unity and completion
and then you could say maybe that we're
manifesting you and i are trying to
manifest that spirit in this dialogue
because we're trying to modify each
other's proximal constructions to move
them towards a more accurate and valid
position and that we're
very engaged when that's happening
because it's so vital
when you know we go away and we think
that was a good conversation that was a
deep conversation we really got
somewhere something like that that
metaphor
we can't simply use engagement as a
barometer or as a marker of
of following this value system because
some people can be engaged heavily so
when murdering people yeah well one of
the things i would
one of the things i warned people about
in maps of meaning was
if you lie enough
you will warp corrupt implicit
structures that guide your interest and
then you won't be able to rely on it and
then you're lost because you imagine if
you couldn't rely on your instinct for
meaning because you'd corrupted it
what are you going to do i think that's
the sin against the holy ghost you know
fundamentally
you can't recover from that
you're speaking my language
i'm i'm liking what you're saying it
reminds me of it's like we have a
compass and every time every lie is a
dis equilibrium a just it makes it
not fro and makes it not operate
properly and so
that's one reason to not tell a line
what's interesting though is that if you
if you've corrupted your compass and the
compass should hopefully lead you
somewhere positive and that depends on
if you're aiming positively
then
telling the truth
recalibrates it
yes i well look psychotherapy i kind of
developed this idea when i went down i
did my first public talk at a bucknell
university about a month ago and
one of the things that i've been writing
about is
that the psychotherapeutic presumption
so the first presumption is that there
is such a thing as psychotherapy the
second presumption is that it can lead
you to a state of increased
psychophysiological well-being and
health
so wait why is there a first let's say
the first assumption necessary what do
you mean that there is such a thing as
psychotherapy well you could just say
that it's just rubbish
right i mean when freud first came out
and said well talking can cure people
you know that was a pretty preposterous
claim no one believed it how can
just talking you know heal it's like
while talking is thinking you don't
think thinking has anything to do with
your psychophysiology and what freud did
was have people just talk they could say
anything he didn't even like that's why
they laid on the couch and didn't see
him it was like say anything that comes
into your mind
okay so
well essentially what you're doing is
telling the truth to yourself in an
untrembled manner now
now people
think by talking most people think by
talking you have to be a pretty good
thinker before you can think without
having to talk and really what you have
to do is talk to yourself in your head
you know you have the revelatory part of
thought which is your ideas and then you
engage in dialectical criticism
internally it's internalized
conversation and you have to be pretty
sophisticated to be really good at that
you have to be willing to divide
yourself into at least two parts and you
have to be able to do that most people
do that by talking so they reveal what
they think to themselves by talking
and then having said what they say they
can you know take it or leave it then
they start to just
distinguish between the wheat and the
chaff
and that can be so is
psychotherapeutically curative and
certainly people like carl rogers placed
a tremendous emphasis on both truth as
the curative process in psychotherapy
but also the
necessity for the psychotherapist
him or herself
to essentially act out something like
the role of christ i mean rogers was
extremely influenced by protestant
thinking i mean he was going to
evangelize the world when he was a kid
but he became agnostic or atheistic but
it all stuck
so the idea was if if i listen to you in
the right spirit
you can reveal truth to yourself that
will
reconstitute you and redeem you that's
basically the whole premise of
psychotherapy and it works you know and
mostly what i saw in psychotherapy i
practiced for 20 years was
we just
we got rid of a fair bit of ignorance
we did a fair bit of social skills
development like i taught a lot of
people how to shake hands and say hello
and introduce themselves because they
just didn't have those skills but a lot
of it was
let's find out the lies man and get rid
of them
and it's up to you to figure out what
the lies are all listen i'm not telling
you i don't know what your lies are i
don't know what lies you're tangled up
in i don't want to presume
yeah and i know some people who would
lie to their therapist because they're
too ashamed or for whatever reason and
some people ask me what am i advocating
for with this film blue better left
unsaid
and for me if i'm not advocating for
anything i'm not like well
be presumptuous for me to advocate would
it mean that i found something that i'm
trying to convince other people of
truly better leftman said was like a an
attempt for me to cohere and and
solidify my own thoughts development so
what did you teach what did it teach
what did it teach you
well
that's simply not easy
and you'll notice that i pause i tend to
pause before i think and one of the
reasons is that it's firstly i'm trying
to if it's something that i've said
before i try to say it in a different
manner and i'll give
well well one reason even if it's
synonyms even if i'm simply replacing
the words with synonyms and the reason
is that
the reason is that well first it's great
for cognitive flexibility i think words
are like batons they allow you to reach
farther places like when you're rock
climbing they're like batons but
secondly because even if it's something
that is the same phenomenon when you
view it from a slightly different angle
you get a better understanding of what
it is
earlier we were talking about idolatry
and i think it's almost idolatry is akin
to mistaking the representation
for what's trying to be represented
so imagine this imagine that you have
and then insisting that that yeah and
insisting that that representation is in
fact the totality yeah
which means insisting that your
interpretation is the totality right the
satanic error
my interpretation is the totality it's
like oh really is it hmm good luck with
that
i'm super excited to talk to you about
the definitions of god and we'll get to
that at some point
so it would be like imagine if you have
an
an upside down ice cream cone so it
looks like this
i did not expect you to say that
all right if you look at it from the
bottom it's a circle if you look at it
from the tops also so if you look at it
from the side it's a triangle if you
look at it from let's say over here or
over here it looks like a teardrop and
so people when they're describing god
what i think they're trying to do is
it's an extremely it may be the most
complicated people say the brain is the
most complicated perhaps god is perhaps
that's one of the definitions of god but
maybe it's not that either way god is
complicated and so to say that well if
you look across religions it's
contradictory therefore what's being
described can't exist or only one of
them can be correct perhaps
now i'm not ecumenical enough to say
they're all correct in their own manner
i'm not under a tree meditating with
with flowers saying that everyone's
correct though that may actually be the
case
i'm saying that just because something
is contradictory doesn't mean that we
shouldn't explore it it may be akin to
different perspectives on the same
object i don't know if you've heard of m
theory it's a form of string theory
string theory says this because there
are five different flavors there's type
two a to b and so on
and it's actually posited that they're
all
not admirations of the same phenomenon
but actually different perspectives of
the same phenomenon
like you touch that this is obvious for
people to understand where the old
refrain if you touch an elephant's ear
touch an elephant's tail touch an
elephant and they're all described okay
so this is obvious to some people
i'm wondering if well i'm not wondering
i have a
i have a distinct feeling the different
descriptions of god even there's so many
contradictory statements between the
east and the west about god um how are
some of the east so this look they're
suffering in life there's also
extreme grace and love in life too but
one of the
one of the solutions is act right
so don't don't lie and then let's say
that's the west's answer then the other
answer is to realize that the suffering
is illusory so to do away with the coin
so one is that the coin look there's a
good side and a bad side so choose the
good that's the west and the east would
say well realize that there is no coin
and that's another solution and perhaps
somehow they're the same solution i've
heard you also i've heard you talk about
stumbling uphill and what lies at the
top of the hills maximal responsibility
is it is that all that lies at the top
of the hill or is it also
is it also warmth and forgiveness and
grace
and are those the same okay how are
those the same okay let's
let's think about this yeah i think well
the responsibility in some sense is is
to lift that load up the hill
you know i that doesn't mean that it's
responsibility that's at the top of the
hill
ah okay
in the in the west i mean in some ways
christ is represented as taking the
responsibility for all the sins of
mankind
unto himself right well that's
responsibility and look to the degree
that each of us are trying to sort out
in our own souls
complex problems that bedevil other
people we're doing that in a low
resolution form right we're taking the
fragility and errors and malevolence of
mankind onto ourselves and trying to
sort that out and that's meaningful
although it's also extremely burdensome
and you know it can kill you it can
crush you and so the responsibility has
to be tempered in a variety of ways to
make it even bearable
you know one of the things that's so
interesting about the christian story in
my estimation is that that
responsibility is so
overwhelming that
you know it it was even
daunting for god himself
so that's built into the story and
that's certainly worth thinking about
you know what's at the top well you
did we we can
we can we can sort of we can hit at it
jung talked about that process that you
described of viewing something from
multiple different perspectives he he
technically called that circumambulation
and it was the attempt to yeah exactly
to view something very complicated like
take snapshots of it from a whole bunch
of different perspectives and this is
partly why very rationally minded people
who like to walk through something
logically find jung
hard to
well tolerate even because that isn't
how he thinks he thinks in this
circumambulatory manner well think of it
this way and think of it this way and
here's another viewpoint and this and
and so forth and then you read that it's
like having an impressionist painting
cohere in your mind into a hole it's
like all of a sudden you go whap oh i
see what he's talking about and that's
an overwhelming experience i mean i
really experienced that reading ion
which is an unbelievably terrifying book
and it's so brilliant it's it's just it
hasn't been unpacked at all into our
culture
it's terrifying because
well young is the only
thinker i've ever seen who you know we
hypothesized earlier in some sense that
that artistic intuition
lays out the map for
the development of propositional
thinking well you'll trace the
development of that intuitive pattern
seeking imagination back like 3000 years
that's partly why he talks about
astrology so
if if he when we looked up in the night
sky let's see
prior to the development of of astronomy
what we saw we didn't know what we were
looking at right it filled us with awe
but we didn't know what we were looking
at so we populated the sky with figures
of our imagination
the better that's the constellations and
it was a way of orienting ourselves so
if you look at astrology
um
psychologically what you have is a vast
storehouse of the contents of the human
imagination
now in astrology there was the idea of a
certain kind of progression through the
eons well jung believed that the fantasy
that underlined astrology was so deep
that it had sketched out the map for the
for the trail that we're actually
walking down
i don't know so reading it
well
so the artists have into well the
artists have intuitions about what's
coming
so they're the first the first people in
the unexplored territory and then the
more
propositional philosophers and such and
the scientists they fill in the details
but the the trailblazing has already
been done by the imaginative and the
intuitive right
right right
an eye on you
it was sorry
on young tracks well that's okay and and
ion young tracks the contents of that
imagination back
several thousand years and also lays out
something like a scheme for the future
so for example he believed that this is
so strange man he believed that the idea
that there were wise men who saw a star
that signified christ's birth was
actually a reference to the astrological
idea that something new would be born at
the dawn of the ancient age of pisces
pisces
well because they were interpreters of
the stars
so pisces
pisces is a constellation that's
characterized by a fish going in one
direction and a fish going in the other
jung was very interested in the use of
fish symbolism in christianity he
associated that with the astrological
imagination he also believed that the
2000 year period from christ's birth
roughly to now was characterized by two
ions one which was explicitly christian
that's the fish moving in one direction
and the other which led to the
development of empirical science was an
antithesis
and that that had been foreshadowed by
the by this by this symbolism which was
part of the intuitive discovery of the
of that which was yet to come
that's only part of the argument and
it's an unbelievably profound book and
it's terrifying once you understand what
he's talking about and i've never seen
anyone criticize it who actually
understood it
you know almost all the criticisms i've
seen of jung and his thinking it's like
no you don't you're not hitting the
target there buddy he's asking questions
that you don't even know need to be
asked
so you know where you're not
you're not in the ball game
so yeah in any case um
the more scientific minded people
yeah well the more propositionally
minded people see jung had a problem
with the propositional universe he said
yeah well there's a gap between what we
know and the unknown per se
well what fills that gap well dreams
dreams the imagination
imagery it's the it's at the boundary of
propositional thought and it it's
between us and what we absolutely don't
know and the visionary artists operate
in the domain of imagination and pave
the path for the propositional types and
think about the relationship say between
dostoevsky and nietzsche nietzsche was
much more propositional than dostoevsky
but dostoevsky fundamentally is deeper
now he's not as clear
right that's the trade-off
everything in nietzsche is in
dostoyevsky and moore is in dostoyevsky
and nietzsche himself knew that i mean
he he was no [ __ ] when it came to
appreciation let's say of works of the
imagination but that's a good way of
thinking and then
you see this too i saw this great
lecture by jonathan pajot which i'm
going to put up on my youtube channel
where he spent about 20 minutes
explaining the meaning of an orthodox
icon that showed
a serpent uh it i don't want to get into
it's too complicated but
there's so much in that image you just
can't believe it and you think well how
did it all get there and it's it's akin
to the question you asked about the
mathematician
it's like who who has plumbed the depths
of the human souls no one
where do these ideas come from well they
appear in my head you think that's an
explanation
the ideas appear in your where in your
head exactly
what do you mean by your head
do you mean physically like what do you
mean
well you don't know what you mean
and god only knows where ideas come from
and to think that they just spring fully
formed out of the void without a huge
developmental history is naive in the
extreme
yeah it's like who built
who built the sistine chapel was it
michelangelo not who built who painted
and well in some sense yes but also his
he came from a myriad of people before
him and not only that but the bible and
also thousands and thousands of years
before to meet these scientists who like
to
like i'm not trying to demean scientists
in any way i mean the rationally
atheistic minded scientists and i'm
strong manning them when i'm saying that
so let me just pick someone kraus so
kraus to
to pick on krauss
krauss would
he looks a phenomenon an extremely
deathless manner now obviously he
doesn't but what i mean is it's almost
like someone who's at the top of the
trees and they're so far up that they
don't realize that there's roots beneath
them that they've forgotten that there's
roots and they think that that they
don't need it they dislike what
well that's part of this that's right
that's exactly that's part of the see
kraus is a great physicist and and
um
but there's a lot of what he does that
he regards as self-evident and
and
and is never questioned and it's sort of
a precondition for what he does as a
physicist because you know if you're a
physicist you're off doing physics
you're not questioning your presumptions
except maybe in the domain of physics
but a lot of what he regards as
self-evident just simply isn't
self-evident
it's not and and that's a real problem
when it comes to discussions about
what's real and
the you brought up an issue a couple of
issues earlier that are really worth
returning to
you know one issue is
what is the one that unites the many
and you might say well we don't need one
that unites the many we can have a
diverse range of values let's say it's
well then you have the problem of
conflict confusion and anxiety plus
hopelessness because you don't really
have a goal
it's not it's not like that polytheism
let's say
is without a cost
it's
it's it's fragmentary
and it causes social havoc because
person a will pursue value a and person
b will pursue value b and that's okay if
they're united under a higher order
structure that unites them in some sense
but it's not okay at all it's it's the
situation in the desert when moses is
leading his people away from from egypt
right
it's the central organizing principle
was the egyptian totalitarian state had
dissolved and what happens is this
descent into a fragmentation
and that's extremely dangerous it's not
the promised land that's for sure so the
question is well what's the one that
unites the many that's the central
religious question
now
so then and but and can't you say that
the one that unites the many is the most
real
well then you're in the domain of
definition right at that point it starts
to become like a definition rather than
yeah
that's why when you
when you ask people to define well what
is real it just becomes tautological
not that by the way not the tautologies
are trivial so for example there's chris
langan he has one of the highest iqs
recorded along with savant i believe
he
builds his theory he builds his theory
of everything in some sense from a super
tautology
that is
that is
it's it's a
it's an appetite that's god's definition
of himself right
i am that i am
that's god's definition of himself in
the bible yeah okay man i think we
should talk about the definitions of god
this is extremely interesting so you
mentioned what's what we tried it one to
one part right well it's well that's a
good question you know i think it's the
spirit that guides our sequential
transformations upward to a higher and
higher form of unity and maybe a higher
and higher form of delight and love do
you think that we're all god i'm sure
you've heard some people say that we're
god but we've forgotten that we're god
i i can't answer a question like that
exactly
i mean i believe that the idea that we
have a divine spark within is an
extraordinarily
beautiful poetic and necessary idea and
i think that if you act like that
to yourself and other people that
things get radically
interesting
interesting and deeply meaningful around
you and it seems to be a very good a
good proposition
to guide your actions you know because
what we're hoping you and me may be to
the degree that we're being good
is that
the spirit of truth in you is speaking
to the spirit of truth in me
and so and that is
a reflection of the presumption
upon which western civilization is based
explicitly let's say
not to say that it doesn't
permeate other cultures
but it's that spirit of truth that
animates us and that redeems us and our
societies as well and hopefully that's
expressed in
the quality of our speech when we're
free to speak
and so is that divine well
is that divine well i don't think it's
separable from thought itself in some
sense it might not be separable from
consciousness itself
is that divine well you know whenever
you have that is that this it's an
equation right
is one plus one equal to two well
one of the answers the radical
each of
well each of those
claims on both
on both sides of the equation are
equally dubious in relationship to one
another
because what you're trying to do is to
say is god real
well what you say what you're not saying
is we know what real is and it's this
and god does god fit into that category
it's also we know what god is in order
to assess it well because you could
reverse it and say is real god
it's the same question right it's the
same question
so here's
one of this this is something i heard
from tyler goldstein who has his own
theory of everything he said
the ordinary ordinarily here's how it
works we look for we have a definition
and then we look for evidence and then
dismiss what we've just defined if we
don't find the evidence he said perhaps
what we should do when it comes to god
is
instead of
instead of looking for god and then not
finding it and then saying god doesn't
exist you use the fact that you didn't
find evidence of god as an indication
that you should alter your definition of
god
yeah well that's that's sure
that's a perfectly real
approach to that problem right obviously
there's some this
yeah
however
now that's a good that's a really good
observation
right it shows you how tricky questions
like that are right it's like well maybe
you're looking in the wrong place
maybe you formulated your search
incorrectly
like you don't know because let's say
you're aiming at the highest reality
right it's like you're aiming at the
highest reality well how do you know you
have the question formulated properly
because if you if you did well you'd
have already found it
and so you might say well does the
highest reality exist
we we're back to the problem of the one
that unites the many yeah yeah i see i
was downtown in toronto and i i just
talked to someone and he's he's his
jamaican guy so if you've well probably
won't happen now it's too cold he was
cutting
coconuts and selling it and i said hey
by the way what's your name he said kurt
i'm like oh my god i rarely meet people
whose name's name is kurt and he's from
the caribbean and i walked away and i
remember thinking uh he has my name and
then i remember stopping thinking no no
he's much older i have his name then i
thought
probably what's better to say is we
share the same name and then i thought
ah okay what is it that we all share and
is that somehow related is that not
synonymous with god
what is it that we all share now here's
something else that i was thinking about
when we
right now we're speaking to one another
in podcast form so in some sense we're
copying this you can think of this
archetypically in some sense we're
copying podcasts by doing so when one is
playing rock music
one is copying rock in some because no
one speaks with a twang where do you
develop that you're copying something
then i thought well how far can you take
that when you're doing art in general
what are you copying okay how far can
that be taken how about right man now
you've got exactly it right how about if
you're simply living laying there
what are you copying
is by simply existing and living is that
a reflection of that what you're copying
is god's essence in some manner
that is abstracted completely i don't
think there's any difference i don't
think there's any difference between
imitation and worship
they're the same thing
that's why the eastern orthodox types
lay such emphasis on the imitation of
christ
well you should worship well pashjo he
says well that means enthusiastically
celebrate
right raised to the highest position
well then you imitate that you imitate
that which is of most value
you imitate hopefully right what else
would you want to do
have you thought much about
self-fulfilling beliefs
you'd have to be worse okay here's the
reason why i say that imagine now
i i believe you outlined this too we've
talked plenty about maps so let's
imagine it's literally like a map just
for simplicity you you construct the
world so you have a world view and it
looks like a top-down view of a
of when you're buying an apartment and
you see the ground layout so imagine
that you're constructing a world view
when it comes to self-fulfilling beliefs
that's extremely interesting to me
because it means there are parts of
reality on that map
that whatever you project to be there
will be there
so let's say i think there's a toilet in
there you're right if you don't think
there's a toilet in there there's
there's not so there are parts of your
map that are always correct no matter
what you think about yeah well okay oh
well okay i would i would turn that a
little bit i would say
this is something kierkegaard talked
about at least to some degree
imagine that there are only things that
you can find out by doing them
so there are there you can't validate
the hypothesis you can't test the
hypothesis without acting it out
so let's say
you decide that you're going to tell the
truth well how what evidence is there
that you should do that well
who knows there's evidence that you
should lie it works in the short term it
might be to your benefit in the short
term i mean maybe if you deceive some
girl she'll sleep with you you know it's
like why not do that
well
you can't collect the facts you know in
some sense
no not in this simple manner well let's
say you decide to
tell the truth as carefully as you can
well then you're going to have a certain
kind of life
and you're not going to have that life
unless you do that and so you won't even
get access to the data unless you
take the steps and that's partly why
faith is necessary especially in an
endeavor like that you have to decide at
some fundamental
level right you know maybe you're
scattered all over the place it's
interesting when christ comes back in
the book of revelation
and he's the judge so he's separating
the damned from the saved let's say
he says something very strange he says
uh if you are neither hot nor cold i
will spit you out of my mouth he
actually says vomit it's so it's a
disgust reaction
and it's it's it's this idea that
it's the worst sin is to play both sides
against the middle
you know
that sometimes you'll lie and sometimes
you'll tell the truth you know you won't
commit to something because you want it
both ways and that's the worst possible
well so let's say you commit to lies
well maybe you'll find out pretty
quickly that that's a hell of a thing to
do and learn what if you don't commit
not
sorry sorry yeah yeah go ahead i was
gonna say what if you don't commit not
because you
believe that you know what's
what's correct and you'd like to lie but
because you simply don't know yeah well
that's why
yeah yeah yeah that's that's a different
that's psychologically that's a whole
different thing i would say
uh well the real damage comes when you
know what you should do and then you
decide not to do it anyways yeah you
know violate your conscience yeah yes it
is the same thing and if you practice
that you're you're going to be in hell
and
you're probably going to drag a fair
number of people along with you if you
have your druthers
so i feel comfortable speculating
because i don't mind sorry i'm so sorry
that i keep interrupting oh man it's my
you're not don't be sorry about it okay
let me say that's fine let me say that
it's fine i i also i don't know if it's
true that you temporarily get what you
want per se when you lie and the reason
is it depends on what you want now
obviously everything depends on
everything you can always say that
depends on so and so but the reason i
say that is that
it's maritricious in some sense you
think you want object x and then it
turns out that you don't when you get it
so i remember in pirates of the
caribbean i could be misremembering this
but there are some gold i think i'm
completely
[Music]
generalizing this but let's imagine
there's some gold
gem that they wanted and it glows and
this guy's like there's only one in the
world it's unique i want this he
eventually goes through this whole
journey he finds it and then he says oh
you know what then he's happy until he
gets to this island where there's
millions it just
as far as the eye can see there are
these gold gems and it just stops he's
like why did i go through all this for
that
and in some sense i'm wondering
hmm
this is the majority of religious texts
telling us you think you want so-and-so
what you actually want is this and in
that way we can say that even the
atheist we can even say that the atheist
ultimately wants god even the serial
killer ultimately wants god well that's
it that's yeah yeah they're distractions
i can't wander down that road with you
at the moment because i'm getting tired
but um i'd like to say one thing about
that deceit issue again and maybe we
could close
if you lie
to a girl and she sleeps with you sure
why aren't you a rapist
and is that actually what you wanted
right because you're you're it's false
pretenses like if you could get away
with it
yeah well so then all of a sudden you
don't have well maybe what you want in
your soul of souls is
you know
this the sexual encounter you'd have in
paradise you know you want love you want
companionship you want the maternal
embrace you want eroticism you want deep
personal contact you want eye to eye
communication that's all part of this
fantasy you know then you deceive
to get it and then you get it well no
you don't because you're a deceitful
rapist
and so what do you get well you get the
corruption of your soul and
the the contamination of the thing that
you want and need most desperately and
that the entire human
endeavor depends upon
and that's probably a good place to
close
it's really good talking to you man yeah
yeah it's great talking to you now
man i wanted to talk about your film
sure sure
okay i wanted to or maybe we did next
point you know what i mean
that's another aspect we can talk about
how much of reality is fractal like
where
the examination of any element if you
pursue it far enough is the examination
of the whole now i know cantor believed
that by studying infinity mathematically
he was studying the mind or studying god
per se and some people think why are you
wasting your time if you're someone who
cares about the good why are you
caring about mathematics or physics or
well hey man maybe if you're truthfully
exploring something you're trying and i
i take questions to your not questions i
take exception to one of your rules
which is
tell the truth i like the i like the the
codicil which is or at least not lie but
i would reverse that i'd say don't lie
and try to tell the truth because it's
much easier to feel like you're telling
the truth when you're not you can trick
yourself and i think the majority of the
time we think we're telling the truth
isn't and that's another reason i pause
because yeah well you just don't start
you start by stopping lying
yeah
it's not easy to discern what is
actually that what i think and what's a
reflex that just comes to me so i'm
trying to make sure
well anyway we can talk about free well
another time
it was really good talking to you man
yeah it was great talking to you with
your continued endeavors and and with
your podcast and
i i really liked your idea about not
saying the same thing twice the same way
that's that's a real interesting mental
habit disciplinary habit
that's smart like what's what's 4 to the
power 4
256 okay so how do you know that you can
memorize it but another way is that you
can go well what's 4 to the power 5.
well that's 2 to the power 10 that's 10
24 if you're a computer scientist you
know that because you deal with bits and
then you can say well what's 2 so what's
4 to the power 3 64. so you can bound it
from each side 4 to the power 3 4 to the
power 5 and then you get a better
understanding of what it means to be 4
to the power 4. so the more
even if it's slight alterations and
you're of saying the same phenomenon of
sorry of trying to describe the same
phenomenon you get a better
understanding of it and when you're
talking about something so complex
i never give the same lecture twice
yeah and that's not easy man no
but it's uh it's pretty damn
entertaining i'll tell you
yeah so before we go i'm curious why it
is that you why is it that you do these
podcasts what are you trying to
accomplish with them so one is obviously
you're trying to learn and obviously
you've attained some level of fame and
wealth so it's not as if you want more
perhaps you do i mean we can't
discount selfish motivations but what is
the reason that you hope the good reason
in you is
to have conversations like this and to
share them with as many people as
possible in the hopes that we'll build
better people and not burn the world
down
yeah
yeah some people say well why is it that
i'm focusing on the left and you
mentioned it's not
see some people caught from the left
called the right reactionary well so
it seems like perhaps what you're doing
on the extreme left you can even if you
feel like the right is more damaging you
don't think you're provoking the right
also the left is more amenable to reason
and at least colloquially it's more
amenable to reasons so i thought perhaps
i should pursue that and i'm more
interested the right is blatant in the
racism so it's like well that's a five
minute film if i'm to analyze the right
and it's yeah so i'll just i'll let
people know about
if they'd like to see
more about me they can visit theories of
everything so you can just type that
into youtube there are conversations
much like this jordan where i'm super
so fascinated no i wouldn't say my
motivations are are pure i'm fascinated
by consciousness physics free will and
god
and
and exploring them with technical depth
as much as i can and not
desprising like most people
i think that disparagement is what
well in many ways is holding us back
so i'm trying to bring some rigor some
exactitude to it because not that's
actually well
we can talk about that and then for
better left unsaid if people want to see
you can go to better left and said
film.com that i try to bring some of the
same analytical framework to exploring
the concept of not exploring the
question of when does the left go too
far and it's such an incomplete film i
disavow it in many ways because it's
it's so incomplete but it's almost like
homework i have to submit it at some
point
yep
enjoyed absolutely thank you man
ciao man really good talking to you
it flew by and uh you're very artificial
thoughtful and you're very careful with
your words and so good for you man
yeah i oh thank you that's a huge
compliment coming from you
good to talk to you
take care man
okay the podcast is over thank you so
much for sticking around for almost
two hours i have some announcements so
some people firstly don't like to sit
through hour long videos or two hours or
three hours not like you you're a
trooper but some people don't like that
they'd rather these five-minute
20-minute 15-minute shareable chunks
there's a clips version of this channel
you just search toe clippings on youtube
a bit cautiously
because there's
clearly some horrific material that will
show up
you'll see the toe logo except it's blue
you can click on that and that's a place
where different sections of the larger
podcast are uploaded also on that same
channel soon maybe even right now i'll
be doing live streams you can check it
out i may be there live streaming
currently with themes that don't exactly
fit the toad channel the main tow
channel plus i don't want to clutter the
main tow channel so for example maybe i
do a live stream with another podcaster
or maybe it's me and i'm studying for a
toe and i'm there just communicating
with the chat while i'm live streaming
in the background the last announcement
is again patreon that is patreon.com
kurtjmungle there should be
a url on screen as well as in the
description the patrons and the sponsors
are the only reason that i'm able to do
toe full time that i'm able to put in
this much energy effort turmoil or or
whatever one wants to call it i happen
to get an extreme amount of excitement
and enthusiasm doing toe toe and my
wife are the
two
aspects of my life that i just i can't
believe how
lucky i am how blessed i am to be able
to do
so visit
patreon.com c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
and even if you're not interested in
contributing because you can't just
visit the site perhaps you can share it
to a friend if they're in the position
where they would like or want to
contribute either way thank you so much
your viewership is more than
contribution enough it's astounding
you're still here you're still listening
to this you're still watching this thank
you thank you and i'm super glad that
you're gaining from toe i hope that
you're gaining from toe it's an extreme
honor and an extreme
privilege to have you
listening watching thank you
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jymungal it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you